it's a shocking death that will spark a
war but how do the final moments of
House of the Dragon differ from the book
the final episode of season one of House
of the Dragon feels like a powder keg
about to be ignited after aegon II is
crowned King at Breakneck speed after
the death of King viserys events are set
in motion that will soon see Westeros
engulfed in war obviously viserys had
named his daughter rhaenyra as air and
this rapid move to usurper Claim by
Alison Hightower and her father Otto has
already created a Schism in the Lords
and Ladies of Westeros however the
coronation of aegon is not without its
hiccups as Princess rhaenis manages to
free her Dragon melees which she uses to
crash through the floor of the Dragon
pit of King's Landing a rather dramatic
way of establishing where rhaenice's
loyalties May lie episode 10 picks up in
the immediate aftermath with rhaenys
explaining to rhaenyra what has just
transpired the greens are coming for you
rhaenera
and for your children quickly summoning
Her counsel as well as her husband and
Uncle Damon Rainier shows far more
restraint than her compatriots who begin
to plan a war of succession pretty much
straight away unfortunately Rainier is
calm and Collective demeanor isn't
exactly rewarded later in the episode as
her careful approach to the conflict is
Shattered by the heedless actions of
children
acknowledging that the faction now known
as The Greens has far more soldiers and
allies rhaenyra dispatches Messengers to
every corner of Westeros hoping to shore
up support after ordering her two
children jacaris and luceris to head to
Winterfell and Storm's end the two
brothers take to their dragons lucerus
Ascend to Storm's end to treat with
boro's Baratheon but he quickly realizes
that somebody has beaten him there
coming face to face with his one-eyed
uncle aymond luceris is unable to
convince boros to lend his support to
his family's side who are now known as
the blacks go home pup and tell your
mother that the Lord of Storm's end is
not some dog that she can whistle up but
need to set against her foes realizing
that he is ill-prepared for this
negotiation luceris attempts to leave
before he is able to depart however
aemond demands that luceras cut out his
own eye to make up for the wound lucerus
had inflicted on aemond in their youth
however boros doesn't particularly care
for this Bluster and allows luceres to
leave taking to his young dragon air ax
who is greatly unsettled by the ongoing
intense storm lucerus begins to fly back
to Dragonstone soon however he realizes
that Ament is in Pursuit with vegar the
largest and most fearsome dragon in
Westeros Eamonn taunts luceris from
atompa's Dragon still demanding his eye
but both children have trouble
controlling their dragons on account of
them being untested Dragon Riders
as eamon's pursuit of luceris becomes
more and more dire lucerus's dragon air
ax is visibly shaken and both dragons
appear to be letting their Primal
instincts take over despite the protests
of both Riders as the hunter vegar size
is incredibly apparent though this
doesn't stop air acts from blasting the
ancient dragon with fire this in turn
causes vegar to release its full Fury
upon both aerax and luceris and in an
instant both dragon and Rider are killed
with a ravenous bite from vegar
this comes as a surprise to aim it who
realizes that his actions will have
deadly consequences as shocking as this
scene was for viewers this scene
actually has far more Nuance than what
was presented in firing blood in the
grand scheme of things this scene is
considered a defining moment in the
conflict known as the dance of dragons
and several different variations of the
story are told regarding what happened
but all agreed upon one thing luceris
and Eric's were tragically undermatched
against aemond and vegar and while you
see that amend is clearly disturbed by
what happened in the show that's not how
it goes down in the book this is on
account of the nature of the way Fire
and Blood is written as a kind of
historical document with unreliable
narrators the book portrays the fight as
one-sided and very much intentional with
aemond motivated primarily by Revenge
there are several stories told about the
aftermath of the fight with some saying
that aerax's head washed ashore others
saying that both luceris and erax were
swallowed hole and one suggesting that
luceris actually survived but suffered
from permanent Amnesia either way
luceris is never found
this change in House of the Dragon makes
for a much more Dynamic story which is
important considering this moment Sparks
the Targaryen Civil War in Westeros
although rhaenyra didn't want to strike
the first blow she was given her wish
albeit at a terrible price to see amond
realize his actions will have disastrous
consequences clearly shines a new light
on the story and it'll be interesting to
see how he'll report the outcome to his
family in an interview with variety
series co-creator Ryan Condell was asked
about why they decided to make luceras's
death an accident and not intentional he
clarified that even though it is
presented as an accident Eamonn still
jumped onto his dragon and chased his
nephew so it isn't as clear-cut as a
simple mistake kondel then explained how
history itself is messy and how the
historians and storytellers of Westeros
couldn't actually know what was going
through eamon's head he added this is a
war of many cuts that lead to a really
really bloody wound it adds complexity
and Nuance to the character that's
potentially interesting discussing the
future of eamon's story condolated
there's lots of Runway to go on with
aemond as a character and the story of
the dance this is his first act as a
dragon rider and a warrior and it's gone
very wrong now what happens as a result
and how does he respond those are the
questions I'm interested in as a
dramatist ultimately this departure from
The Source material definitely adds yet
another layer to the upcoming conflict
and the way both signs will respond and
shape the history of Westeros
foreign